freunde es ist mal wieder zeit ein tag
essen wie in einem besonderen land ihr
habt schon längst gelesen spanien ich
freue mich sehr darauf die spanische
küche ist glaube ich relativ weit
verbreitet in deutschland ich selbst
gehe aber nie einfach mal so spanisch
essen jeder kennt glaube ich irgendwie
laden wo man tapas essen kann aber was
steckt alles noch mehr dahinter so was
sind die geheimnisse wie ist man
wirklich in spanien ich habe mich damit
auseinander gesetzt freue mich auf ein
frühstück mit dem man wahrscheinlich
nicht gerechnet hätte und auch ansonsten
wird es einfach ultra lecker deshalb
viel spaß mit dem ihr merkt es wird laut
es wird belebt dank für diese wunderbare
musik wir sind auf der schildergasse
oder hohe straße kenne mich ja so
schlecht aus wie hier aber hier gibt es
shows und ich nachts bei meiner
recherche moment mal so ist das nicht so
ein snack zu halten bisher aber man ist
es traditionellerweise in spanien zum
frühstück das machen wir jetzt
[Musik]
dargestellt mamma mia leute ich sag's
euch wirklich mindestens
jeder bedient das war es jetzt mit der
innen innenstadt für mich wieder für ein
halbes jahr will airbus frisch
ausgebacken knusprig in öl obendrauf mit
schokoladensoße ich habe noch den
betreiber von laden gerade getroffen und
er meint in spanien ist man die häufig
auch herzhaft also hier ist ein süßer
ansatz und kleiner süßer warme snacks
kennt man ja auch so von
weihnachtsmärkten von jahrmärkten aber
wir sehen schon sehr gut aus die sind
wie auch schön frittiert attacken
[Musik]
gehören will einfach nur mehr etwas
süßes du hast das los bringt knusprigen
schöne konsistenz und innen übels luftig
oder sage ich euch mal
das krank ich denke es besteht
wahrscheinlich ein klassischer teil
eines frühstücks bei so fettig die so
süß kann man nicht jeden tag in der
tasche hatten das ding ist so seifert in
spanien auch mal irgendeine art von
einem brot oder einem panini oder brot
belegt mit irgendwas auch gegessen weil
wir wollen ja auch die besonderen dinge
erreichen das ist halt eben traditionell
zum frühstück mann ist wie auch in
frankreich oder italien häufig süßes
gebäck zum frühstück also auf minecraft
aber das hier ist wirklich eine
besonderheit gibt in spanien und es ist
wie bei schlecker also kann es nichts
dagegen sagen es macht süchtig ich fühle
mich danach auf jeden fall nicht fit
aber ich ab lecker gegessen ab zum
mittagessen nächster stopp einladen bin
ich schon ganz lange ausprobieren wollte
kamen und rosa ein kleiner wirklich
winziger spanischer supermarkt der auch
einen mittagstisch hat immer ein gericht
traditionell spanisch wir gehen hin wir
gucken was es dort zu entdecken die
welche lebensmittel es gibt aber ich
finde gerade so delikatessen geschäft
spiegelt auch so ein land einfach so in
der vielfalt in der kulinarik einfach
wieder das gibt es dort was sind die
besonderen dinge so die barrick
beschenken werden wir bestimmt sehen
aber es gibt es noch so zimmer einfach
wieder lust auf essen ich war aber nach
dem frühstück knockout das hat mir meine
ganze energie geraucht aber ich freue
mich jetzt auf etwas besonderes
okay wir sehen schon allein schon diese
auswahl die wir hier an auch hinein so
spanischen produkten habe sind halt
einfach delikatessen bei sowas rege ich
mich immer auch wenn ich die sprache
nicht kann ich generell ich bin immer so
mich geärgert immer total wenn ich im
land bin und die sprache nicht kann
hier gibt es gründe er mich verschiedene
these two reasons sorge die namen
ausspricht angst weil sie alles falsch
sagt was sieht so gut aus hätten wir was
kochen wollen hätten wir hier perfekt
einkaufen es gibt hier zur mittagszeit
immer noch ein einziges gericht dass er
mir drin wolfsbarsch gelee mit
karamellisierten zwiebeln und kartoffeln
und auch dieses gericht ist jetzt
vielleicht kein prominentes gericht aber
auch ganz klassisch waren das finde ich
aber auch richtig cool dass man nicht so
super stereotyp ist sondern dass es auch
einfach authentisch also einfach so was
essen welches wirklich dort gegessen
wird genauso wie man in amerika
natürlich wirklich berger ist gibt es
dann halt auch irgendwie so spezielle
sachen auch das dann so ein bisschen
schinken wissen freue ich mich sehr
drauf
dankeschön
wir sind angekommen erstmals wolfsbarsch
kartoffeln das alles 97 punkte der
mädchen karamellisierten zwiebeln so
eine orange große etwas was so ein
bisschen aussieht wie tesco und darunter
eben der wolfsbarsch ich probiere
einfach mal die kartoffeln ich glaube
die sind wahrscheinlich
ich finde wenn man das so liest das
gericht dann hätte man nicht das
erwartet weil das so hätte man niemals
das interpretiert weil wir es niemals
spanisch interpretieren gehören der
wolfsbarsch fällt auch richtig immer ein
bisschen von den karamellisiertem
zwiebeln dazu
diesen höchst karamellisiert sind
richtig süß der wolfsbarsch ist umzäunt
gebraten richtig gut man kann sich ja
vorstellen dass hier ein großes
verständnis für gutes essen herrscht bei
meiner musik ausmachen den ganzen laden
so einer landeskirche wird mit dann wird
man auch kaufen können und das können
wir auf jeden fall kommentierten
zwiebeln um drauf sind sowieso eine
zwiebel marmeladen so ein bisschen die
kartoffeln auch kalt daten sind ja ok
sowas hätte auch nicht erwartet oder
hätte ich nicht erwartet diese
geschmacks zusammen das kenne ich auch
gar nicht deshalb nicht gut dass wir das
ziel unsere video hat haben mal so
stelle ich mir vor wird in spanien
gegessen und dieses geschmacks ist
einfach was neues gibt es auch niemals
bestellt während woanders gewesen hätten
wir es nicht so vorgegeben bekommen ich
tun damit richtig ermutigt
beziehungsweise gezwungen was
auszuprobieren
und was haben wir hier vor uns noch war
das hier ist jetzt ein absoluter traum
in verschiedene bürsten
ja so ein bisschen shape sind das macht
immer so eine gute juli aus wenn sie so
ein bisschen
relativ kalten juli ist auch so holzer
eine ford haben wir eine katalonische
salami
weil wir so ein ding so was hier das
kennen wir gar nicht so diese kultur bei
uns ist so aufschnitt häufig wirkt ganz
häufig einfach ja so ein mittel zum
zweck also irgendwas was wir morgens auf
brot knallt und das sind genuss mit also
die lange gereift sind die eine
geschichte haben so die mega lag dass
wir etwas ist weil ich älter werde und
wann ich verstehe weil ich gutes essen
also zu schätzen gelernt habe personen
brett zunächst glas wein das ist feiert
das wirklich einfach genutzt die barrick
verstehen ganz wichtig
also wirklich das hauptgericht käse und
schinken juni fühlt man sich wirklich so
verbunden so zu dem land etwas ressel
etwas ganz anderes ist so eine eigene
küche unfassbare kritisch und meinen
spanien ausdruck macht bisher sehr viel
spaß also ich war jetzt sehr gespannt
darauf weißt du was jetzt brauchst
so eine richtig geile csd wenn ich das
auch wer braucht schon sehr opulent das
ist auch klassischer weise sorgt für ein
bisschen mehr gegessen mittagspause ein
stückchen wandelt worte noch verschenken
gibt man immer was geschenkt in spanien
alles was mit mandel ist es auch nicht
so trocken ist immer saft ich muss
herausfinden weil es sowieso lecker ist
seit jahren nicht feucht am mandelkuchen
das beschreibt sehr gut dreigängige
mittagsmenüs ganz klassisch danach jetzt
in den mittagsschlaf so zeigt das
abendessen zu erster vorbei ich habe
geschlafen wie ein stein nein ich war
wirklich nackt auf der couch also einen
großen mittagessen hat was aber danach
bist du erst mal du brauchst du pause
aber in spanien ist es dann so heiß dass
man sie sich sowieso nehmen muss wir
sind jetzt beim essanelle córdobas hier
gibt es ab was gibt's da gibt es ganz
viele verschiedene dinge und ich bin
sehr gespannt wir haben den laden
empfohlen bekommen von dem chef von
carmen und ruß also wo wir gerade eben
waren deshalb muss es gut sein die sind
ja spanier gehen wir mal rein und gucken
aber
lecker
direkt aus
eine andere welt alles auch komplette
rest zuhause aus gut 3000 plätze sind
ausgebucht also wir gucken dass wir
haben auf jeden fall unmengen von
verschiedenen tapas variationen gucken
wir mal hier primär endlos patrone nicht
lackierte spanischen paprika steht
genauso der unterrock krone ist in wien
arena den essig eingelegte mit knoblauch
sind das glaube ich in salla da war ja
da gemischter salat wir müssen auch
tapas gehen würde aber einfach eine
variation so fünf verschiedene tapas ja
nie so ganz klassisch ist also auch
spanien auch sparen urahn aller matteoli
oliven und der shake test wieder guck
mal wieder wie wackelpudding die tester
sehr gut vor der saison sehr knoblauch
und deswegen weniger als die wirte
mittag abend noch etwas peppiger aber
uns verstärken
ich merke schon dass sind alles
situationen
genau um authentische gebeten da gibt's
april
[Musik]
wollen die kennt man glaube ich auf
jedem papa sagt und die anderen sind
habe ich schon so ein bisschen
authentischer geheimtipps vielleicht
vielleicht auch nicht das muss jetzt als
erste probleme sieht so unerwartet auch
so dieses kann mit ein bisschen aus wie
hühnerfrikassee
frank rost schmeckt lecker
schmeckt
dort lockt auch die datei mit der sonst
so sehr sehr lecker aber die jungs ist
mega gut was mich am meisten
interessiert ist ja auch noch immer das
gefühl in den meisten ländern sind die
einfachen gerichte die häufig so ein
bisschen das resteessen sind ja besser
weisen im gesamtbild nicht zu sehr
kaputt gedacht ist oder so ein dass sie
für mich so aus als genauso ein gericht
das war wirklich auch sagen muss auf
hähnchen hier ist ultra partnern das
feld auseinander
[Musik]
ein kranker fettgehalt wahrscheinlich ne
sie schuldig so zerfällt wirklich hab
dann vielleicht nicht so schnell biss
mich einmal quer durch probiert damit
das video 20 minuten lang ich glaube
lässt sich wirklich sagen das ist durch
die bank gut also wo wir die anleger
kannst nicht leicht aber irgendwas
heiraten oder so deutlich besser als bei
anderen teilen können das sagt so kenne
ich das gar nicht die vielfalt möglicher
jedes mal beim papas essen macht es
einfach nur spaß aber man kann jetzt
hier so drei stunden lang sitzen die
ganze zeit irgendwie kleinigkeit rein
fressen das ist eigentlich so einfach so
dieses genießen auf die spitze getrieben
hat einfach nur zu hoffen dass auch er
abends beschäftigung das ist nicht so
ich geh essen und danach mache ich was
sondern ich gegessen und dabei mache ich
was so das ist um die beschäftigung wenn
manchmal wären sie ein gericht gestellt
denkt man sich drauf hat ich hätte auch
gerne das gab es ja noch das gab
probiert bei freunden das kannst du
alles an einem abend haben oder ganz
genau diese perfekte portion
probierportionen von allen gerichten
genau einmal ist er war nur mit den
manche gruppen wir essen was klein ist
ihr merkt denke das ganze durch
probieren dann sitzen wir noch bis
morgen wir sitzen ob es morgen aber das
video können wir langsam würde ich sagen
gegen ende laufen lassen ich finde das
ist so ein aktives essen so ein aktives
essen gehen viel mehr als wenn man sich
einfach nur eingerichtet forscht mal so
wir das auch so zu tapas und aktiver
kannst du dann essen wenn du irgendwie
green party gemacht also aber dann liegt
die arbeit bei dir du hast du es viel
spaß und abwechslung
[Musik]
durch jedes mal nach so einem tag essen
wie im abschluss für das ist die geilste
landeskirche überhaupt entdeckt habe
aber dass genau das kleine soll jede ist
für sich genommen einfach mega mega nice
die spanische kann auch so viel zu
bieten und ich mir ganz sicher dass wir
nur ein bruchteil gesehen haben heute
deshalb bin ich froh das video sprache
und das ist immer unendlich ist sagen
wir uns beim nächsten video wieder bis
dahin absolut
okay
nee das ist okay wurzeln
ich sag doch was anderes
6 mbit
mit